anthony congrats on the win explain to
me what was going on with the team when
you guys went from the 23-point lead to
the two-possession game under a minute
turnovers we had too many turnovers
i had two um
you know we gave them easy looks they
made threes you know eric gordon great
shooter
a couple threes couple layups we gotta
be better um closing out games
um luckily we did have a 20-point lead
where it didn't hurt us but
you know we got to be better going into
next game knowing these guys not gonna
quit
um you know that's all they're saying we
coming we're not gonna quit
and they aren't you know they got guys
who can make plays for them guys who
could shoot the basketball
and cut the lead you know they shoot a
lot of three so it's easy for them to
get back in games and we gotta be better
take care of the ball
and execute on offense before the fourth
quarter you took all of the explosion
out of a team that is
one of the most explosive offenses in
the league what was working and what did
you guys finally figure out defensively
to completely cut off their three-point
game
we played defense took away the threes
you know except towards the end
you know we did a good job defending the
three and taking them out their rhythm
you know you know made it tougher jane
made it tough for us made it tough for
eg you know but like i said we gotta be
better towards the end of the game
you know but for the most part you know
for 45 minutes of the game we
we actually hit our game plan and you
know the last three minutes we got to be
better but you know i think we play
great defensively and
uh they're not going to go away but we
got another tough one
whenever we play again uh and knowing
that they
you know elimination game is always the
toughest you know because team's not
gonna quit so
you know we gotta come out with a with a
you know killer mindset that we're going
to finish the series what did you think
about the rookie horton tucker who had
some good quality minutes and what can
you tell me about him because
we haven't seen him much this season he
he likes to work he likes to play
he's a great learner fast learner and he
comes in and give us everything he can
defend
he can make shots as we see him make
plays made a big three
got to the basket for a layup and made
some great some great plays on the
defensive end so
he don't get that much time but he's
always ready you know he's always
listening and
you know his bet on this team is
everybody but his main bet is j.r and jr
always in his ear about
what you should do ask him questions
about the game plans just in case
like tonight he goes and he knows what
he's doing so um you know
he's a great rook and he played well for
us tonight thanks for your time anthony
congrats on the win yep
guys